cloud migration is top of mind for many
organizations today while moving to the
cloud can be full of challenges the
cloud offers many advantages around
increased agility new and innovative
services and on-demand pricing that
traditional data centers don't offer so
let's talk about one way to make
migration easier hosting your native
VMware environment right on Google cloud
the reality is that managing your own
infrastructure is often an unnecessary
burden and usually isn't a
differentiator for the business while
migrating to the cloud is the end goal
there can be significant complexity and
refactoring applications as well as the
tools and policies your teams use the
challenge of migration can involve risks
and put your business and analysis
paralysis Google cloud wants to help
businesses capture the benefits of cloud
while reducing the complexity of doing a
full record today we're going to show
you how that's possible with Google
Cloud VMware engine a fast and safe way
to move your VMware workloads to the
cloud Google Cloud VMware engine is
built to address the biggest issues that
prevent most workloads from moving to
the cloud lack of resources and the cost
of reaaargh attacking apps with Google
Cloud VMware engine you can migrate your
apps with zero changes you'll be able to
run your VMs in a private native VMware
environment this means you can use the
same tools processes and policies while
still getting the advantages of being in
the cloud on top of deeper integration
with other Google cloud services in fact
it doesn't take long to spin up an
environment you can lower your total
cost of ownership quickly and spend more
time planning on how to re architect
down the road let's walk through a demo
of how to set up a Google Cloud VMware
environment with just a few clicks
we'll start by showing how to access the
Google Cloud VMware engine from the
Google Cloud console after that we'll
create a secure an isolated boundary
called a private cloud that will contain
the VMware environment then we'll take a
tour of some of the platform features
and jump into the familiar vSphere
interface let's start with the icon in
the upper left-hand corner of the
console scroll down to the compute
section and you'll see VMware engine
clicking on this takes us to the
overview page which provides additional
details and lets us do common operations
like creating our private cloud viewing
documentation launching the vSphere
client modifying network settings and
managing users
let's create a private cloud by clicking
on the create private cloud button here
we'll be able to customize our cloud by
choosing a location let's leave it on
u.s. east and increase the number of
nodes from 3 to 4 will also add a side
arrange for our appliances and then
click review and create after reviewing
that everything looks good we'll click
create to kick off the process once
completed we can see the details of the
environment as well as other private
clouds that we've created while the
private cloud is being created let's
talk about pricing pricing is done per
node and includes all the storage
compute and licensing to run a VMware
environment by default you'll pay per
month but you can also sign up for a one
or three year plan to save money all of
the billing for VMware engine is
integrated so you can see payment
details side by side with your other
Google cloud services after your private
cloud is created you can access it from
the resources screen here you can see
all of your private clouds and manage
them by clicking on a specific private
cloud you can see the details of its
configuration here you can launch your
virtual center client which is the
standard enterprise virtual center
client you're likely already familiar
with you can also expand the cloud by
adding nodes as well as scrolling down
to the bottom where you can shrink your
environment escalate your privileges so
you can get admin access and virtual
center or even delete the private cloud
entirely let's go back up to the top of
the screen and launch the vSphere client
on this login page we can enter our
credentials after logging in you can see
that we're working with the same
interface that you and your team are
likely already familiar with this native
access to vmware gives you a standard
way to control your applications while
getting all the benefits of running on
google cloud now let's return to the
Google Cloud VMware engine management
console and look at some of the
networking details here we can manage
and set up our VLANs and subnets
firewall tables public IP addresses VPN
gateways and VP CP rings where you can
easily access your Google Cloud
infrastructure from your VMware
environment the activities interface
provides details that your security and
operations teams will be interested in
it provides any alerts that have
occurred in the environment details on
any events that have occurred in the
past current running tasks and allows
you to audit any activities done by a
user the accounts screen gives you an
overview of your entire
VMware engine environment including the
ability to sign up for email alerts
you're also able to manage the users who
have access to the environment
we're eager for everyone to see Google
Cloud VMware engine and are excited to
say that it's available for you to try
out right now
with this quick tour you should be ready
to migrate your VMware environment to
the cloud quickly check out the
documentation and see more details and
spin up your own private cloud
[Music]